HOW FACEBOOK WORKS AND OUR
UNDERSTANDING OF IT VERY CLEAR.
>> Tucker: THANK YOU,
APPRECIATE IT.
JOHN KENNEDY OF LOUISIANA WAS
ONE OF THE SENATORS WHO SPOKE TO
ZUCKERBERG TODAY.
>> HERE'S WHAT EVERYBODY'S BEEN
TRYING TO TELL YOU AND I SAY
THIS GENTLY.
YOUR USER AGREEMENT SUCKS.
[LAUGHTER]
I'M GOING TO SUGGEST TO YOU THAT
YOU GO BACK HOME AND REWRITE IT.
TELL YOUR LAWYERS, NO
DISRESPECT, THEY'RE GOOD.
TELL THEM YOU WANT IT WRITTEN IN
ENGLISH.
>> Tucker: SENATOR KENNEDY
JOINS US.
THINGS WERE COMING ON.
>> WHAT YOU BET.
>> Tucker: WHAT WAS THE POINT
OF THIS HEARING?
WHAT ARE YOU CONSIDERING WITH
FACEBOOK?
>> I WAS MILDLY DISAPPOINTED
WITH THE HEARING.
I WANTED MR. ZUCKERBERG TO STEP
UP AND SAY I'M ON IT.
I DID IT, IT CAN BE FIXED.
I'M GOING TO FIX IT.
WE'LL DO IT TOGETHER.
THAT'S NOT WHAT I HEARD.
I DIDN'T FEEL LIKE WE CONNECTED
WITH MR. ZUCKERBERG TODAY.
FACEBOOK IS AN EXTRAORDINARY
COMPANY.
IT'S DONE MAGICAL THINGS, BUT
IT'S CLEAR THAT THE DIGITAL
PROMISED LAND HAS SOME
MINEFIELDS IN IT.
ONE IS THE PRIVACY ISSUE, THE
OTHER IS THE PROPAGANDA.
I DON'T HAVE TO VOTE TO REGULATE
FACEBOOK, BUT WE'RE ALMOST
WILLING TO STEP UP TO THE PLATE
AND ADDRESS THOSE TWO ISSUES.
I THINK THEY CAN, I HOPE THEY
CAN.
IF THEY CAN'T COME OUT WITH THAT
A BIGGER PROBLEM THAN JUST WHAT
WE TALKED ABOUT TODAY.
>> Tucker: HERE YOU'VE GOT THE
BIGGEST PROVIDER OF NEWS IN THE
UNITED STATES WITH MORE POWER
THAN WILLIAM RANDOLPH THE FIRST
EVER HAD WITH A LONG AND PROVEN